god is good and all the time
good morning
it's everyone on yeah all right no problem
test just
hear
god is good and all the time all right i am
delighted to see those of you who've come
and i believe with all my heart god will bless us
as we listen to his word i had a
difficult time determining what to say
and as i listened to dr lemon this morning i
was standing back here heard the whole thing i
realized that the mic wasn't working all right it
is the devil does everything he can should i take
give you this all right my good
brother and this as well okay
all right there you go i think
something is wrapped around something
yeah really oh nope this way
okay no trouble at all it's all right okay god
is good and all the time i welcome you to this uh
presentation this morning it's oh it's actually
12 o'clock on the dot i also welcome those who
are listening on the internet i know with
a certainty there's some friends of mine
listening in east africa we welcome you and hope
that god will bless you as you unite with us even
though we are separated physically by thousands
of miles we are one in heart and spirit and so
i just want you to say god bless you to my friends
in east africa just say it loudly god bless you
all right and by faith we can hear them
say god bless us and we're happy uh
do three things for me i want to move quickly
because we have a long day ahead of us
favor number one do you have you already
switched off your cell phones proactively
who has done that all intelligent
people who've already done that
let me see your right hand all right hands down
the rest of you uh please do that now please
god bless you some people are slow some are
fast but by god's grace the slow can become
fast what do you say never be fast and become
slow if you slow become fast faithful number
two while i'm speaking pray for me and all i want
you to say is god lord put your words whose words
god's words were in that man's mouth because my
words really have no power and also because god
works through vessels of clay and iron clay
dirt the worst kind of dirt there's always a
risk that as the message is delivered some dirt
will come out on the message are you with me
but when you say put your words in that man's
mouth then you protect your own mind because god
will hear your prayer he will give me the words
and what enters your mind will be safe so when
you say god put your words in that man's mouth it
is not strictly for my benefit although i benefit
it is also for your benefit because everything
i say that enters your head once you hear it you
cannot get it out of your head then please make
sure that you're listening to the right thing
so ask god to put his words in my mouth
and faith number three i want you to think
it is not a privilege to speak to people who
don't think no it isn't it's tremendous hard work
will you think say yes all right i want someone
to come and pray for me someone who loves god
come and ask god to use me
somebody come i said who will come
benjamin is it come benjamin son of my right
hand that's what benjamin means come my good
brother god bless you ask god to use me and
to touch the hearts of those who are listening
our father which are in heaven lord this morning
father we pray father for our brother randy skeet
lord that you will please give him words father
it is dangerous for us to listen to the words
of a man when we listen to the words of god we
are changed and transformed by your holy spirit
father i ask that every mind here every heart
might be open to hear the words that are presented
because i know they come straight from the
throne room of heaven father we're thankful for
these gifts we pray all these things in christ's
name because you are faithful and you promise to
receive us lord and to answer our prayers we
thank for these gifts in christ's name and for
his sake amen amen thank you brother benjamin
may the lord bless you with a wife who can cook
and so and run a home and as a queen in
the sunshine in that home can you say amen
we have too many wild women running
around the place we need some women who
are made in the image of god are you with
me let me tell you what i want to talk about
now for those listening internationally let
me explain something that's peculiar to the
united states terminologies in the u.s when a man
runs around with a lot of women we call him what
what's another word three letters a dog are you
with me he's a dog so when you hear me if i use
this term again my international viewers it means
a man who women usually refer to as running around
but i want to say right up front and you'll
get some clue as to the direction of my remarks
no man can be a dog by himself
uh you miss what i said as i listened to dr lemon
i realized that much of my remarks perhaps may
repeat what he said but hopefully in a different
way and that's just the spirit of god working
let me say it again differently
for every man who is a dog there is
a woman
who enables him to be a dog because
a man cannot be a dog by himself
my question for you women are
you helping men to be dogs
by the way you dress
by the way you carry yourself
by the non-unspoken signals you give
this is serious business and this message is
based upon a biblical principle which i now
introduce to your consciousness go with me
to genesis chapter 2 we shall read verse 7.
genesis 2 verse 7. do you have that
can't be that hard to find genesis
you have chapter two what verse did i say
now you want to read this verse
without looking all heads look up
genesis 2 verse 7 the bible says and the lord
god formed man of the dust of the ground say it
then breathe into his nostrils
the breath of life finish it
and man became a living soul now let's go to verse
21 of genesis 2. and this time you may look down
and the lord god caused the deep
sleep to fall upon man and he slept
and he took one of his ribs and closed up the
flesh instead thereof and the rib which the
lord god had taken from man made he a woman and
brought her into the man we have the biblical
record of the creation of the first man and
the first woman both made on the sixth day
god made notice the wording of genesis 22
and the rip which the lord god had taken from
man made here a woman so we have a man and
we have a woman meaning god made two adults
i'm trying to present a principle you
see behavior must be based on principle
not just on laws laws express principles
the law of god existed before the fall
of man or else adam could not have sinned
after the transgression of adam the
principles of the law were not changed
but were definitely arranged and expressed
to meet man in his fallen condition
are you with me what ellen white is saying
that prior to sin the law existed really as
a principle but because of sin which
limited the power of comprehension god
had to express them in a way that we can
understand and i usually explain it this way
i travel quite often so does dr jackson with
lemon and others who speak a lot of the parks
when you're in a plane let's say you're 747
let's say i'm going from detroit to johannesburg
15 hours fly to atlanta atlanta johannesburg
15 hours you're in a plane double decker you're
traveling about 600 miles per hour 30 000 feet now
6 600 miles per hour that's safe at 30 000 feet
you don't drive 600 miles per hour
in the parking lot of the church
are you with me that would be unsafe if
you end up in prison now the speeds differ
but the principle is the same which is safety
are you following me so on highway was it 10
is it 10 east takes you to melinda is that okay
then you do what 55 or 70 something like that
that is fine so you've got 600 at 38 000
feet you've got five miles per hour in
this very narrow parking lot you've got 25
miles in a school zone during school hours
you have 45 in construction in michigan of course
in construction where the workers present you're
45 if you're injured worker it's 7 500 and
15 years that's the way it is in michigan
all the speeds vary but what remains constant is
the principle of safety now if the principle of
safety is embedded in my heart i don't
need a law that says 55 miles per hour
ah come on you're not listening no one on that
side said anything nor that side so you've got
company let me tell you again by saying it this
way how many of you have children raise your hands
anyone has a baby right now anyone
breastfeeding take your hand down brother
no all right anyone pregnant
no okay let's say you're breastfeeding
do you need a law to tell you breastfeed
why why do you not need the law you have a natural
love and affection for your child you don't need a
policeman or some judge to tell you it is written
this place and that place that code to feed your
child you do it naturally because the principle
of maternal love drives you the love of the child
constrains you as the love of god
should constrain us that's the principle
today i want to give a principle
that should underlie all behavior now
and so god made a man and god made a woman
god did not create the same way children
god could have made eight million
adults the same way he made two
is everyone with me and there would have been no
need for rearing of children you would have been
made or we adults yes character development
that's always inevitable that will take place
in a new world but we would have been made fully
grown developed adults but god did not do that god
arranged that after adam and eve every human
being would be born into the world and would
have to grow up surrounded by the influences
of others and the influences of those others
would determine to a very large degree
the shape of that person's character
can i take this off i can
i keep leaning forward and it constricts the
vocal passage can this be loosened in any way no
i don't want to cause a technological disturbance
there's a wireless mic does it work all right
it's working no it's working yes all right my
brother thank you for being helpful god bless you
influence when a child is born that child is
a blank slate and the only thing written on
that slate is carnal nature are you with me the
influences that surround that child will determine
the degree to which that nature
is expressed or suppressed
i have a picture on my ipad
someone sent me a beautiful picture
and i want to uh well you won't be able to see
it very well but uh maybe did i get rid of it i
don't i probably got rid of it i think i did it's
a beautiful little picture of a white child and a
black child right next to each other just hanging
out and neither one knows the color of the other
are you following me now you take that little
black child or that little white child whichever
and whether that black child or
that white child becomes a racist
is almost entirely dependent upon the the
the environment in which that child grows up
sociologists have discovered that children pick up
social signals and attitudes at a very young age
influence it is by divine arrangement
that children are to grow up under the
influence of a home that is why the home must be
of a kind of a type that the influence it exerts
will develop that child in the direction of heaven
my burden today is influence that's one i have two
here's what alawite writes about
influence in historical sketches
page 143 paragraph 5. listen carefully we are
all woven together in the great web of humanity
and god holds us responsible for
the influence we exert over others
now you miss what i just said the severity and the
gravity of my remark not my remarks the statement
from ellen y we are all woven together in the
great web of humanity in a certain sense now
the christian is separated from the world but at
a biological physical level we are still connected
because even though we may be separate and we
live in a country and we have a certain diet a
certain dress which are all proper and required
we are still visible to the rest of the world
and when you walk out just the way you dress has
an effect on people who watch you the way you walk
has an effect on people who watch you the way you
shop has an effect on people who watch you i was
i came into flew into los angeles about three
years ago to speak of the church and the pastor
picked me up and he said are you hungry i said
yes and it's not a sin to be hungry by the way
and we went to a restaurant somewhere in l.a left
the airport so the lady brought the menu to us
and he scanned his and i scanned mine and he
picked and i think and we didn't collaborate
when the waitress came for our orders she looked
at his order and she looked at mine and she said
are you vegetarians and he said yes and she
said i want to be a vegetarian but i can't
now she was influenced by our menu choices and
we were not thinking of influencing anyone they
were we were too hungry man are you with me
trying to stave off starvation and so we chose
but when she saw our choices she
realized that we ate differently
and so our menu behavior influenced her to say i
would like to be a vegetarian but i can't when she
said that i heard a cry for help and so i told the
pastor get the book councils on dance and foods
or ministry of healing have the entire church
border eldest board sign it come back to this
restaurant find that woman and give it to
her whether he did or not i don't know but
that was what i told him she was influenced
by the simple act of making a menu choice
people ask me all the time how do you memorize why
do you do it may god rest the soul of an old elder
who served in my church when i was a little boy
whenever that man stood in the pulpit
to preach he opened his bible as i do
but he never looked down he
always preached from his head
now here am i sitting in church little
boy 13 short pants in my day you couldn't
wear long pants until you were old enough
are you with me you had rights of passage
today every boy is a man every girl is a
woman in my day sure in my day i can say it
girls wore bows socks flat shoes so a
man would look and know that's a girl
today some men don't know who's a girl who's a
woman no no no i'm not joking now i don't support
pedophiles are you with me i don't whether it's
a male pedophile or a female pedophile but let me
tell you many men are confused is that a woman or
is that a 13 year old girl because they're dressed
the same way but anyway back then i'm in my
short pants i was a boy not a man and i'm
sitting watching this man preach and he never knew
it he died not knowing the influence he had on me
influence and i said to myself in my 13
year old mind i would love to do that
and it stayed with me and it stayed with me and
when i travel now there are young boys i meet
who come to me what do you think
they say i would love to do that
what do you call that influence
god made two adults everyone else comes as a child
and much of what a child becomes is the result of
the influences that surround that child counsels
to parents teachers and students page one or two
paragraph two ella white writes these words god
holds everyone responsible for the influence that
surrounds his soul on his own account and on the
account of others in other words in the judgment
many women will be held partially
responsible for the immoral behavior of men
notice how i use the key
word what's that partially
because men ultimately have to make up their
own minds i was in i go to uganda quite often
and in uganda i usually
stay in hotels right in town
and at night the ladies of the night they hang
around the hotels and they dress a certain way
and you heard dr lemon refer to that text in
proverbs this young man saw a woman in the attire
of an ireland do you know why
prostitutes dress the way they dress
because they know if they can get a man to do what
to look the possibility of a sale
exists why because men are visual
women are visual too but not the way men are
women are affected by what you say to them
largely a man is visual and so
cheerleaders how are they addressed
are they dressed in gowns arms covered no because
their their purpose is to appear to the men
because the men control the money whether it's a
football cheerleader or a basketball cheerleader
now i'm from a part of the world where people play
cricket you may not know what cricket is in india
in some places now they've introduced cheerleaders
at cricket games they've been quickly bangladesh
cheerleaders on the cricket
field had never heard of that
but the world knows the effect
of a half-naked woman on a man
and that problem is in the church and
so every sabbath men come to church
they are struggling because here's
a woman who knows she has a big
and she deliberately wears
a tight skirt to emphasize
and the man is trying to keep his mind all she has
and where's a tight blouse and the bus line
meets where the hemline meets and the man
are you with me it is wrong in the sight of god
my first point this morning you are responsible
for the influence you exert on people
i have a friend who lives in florida husband's
a pastor good man she says that i've known the
years 40 more of most or more years she
said randy why do you always fly in a suit
which i always do i said because of the work
that i do and i'm talking i'm not preaching
i'm talking to you from time to time people at
airports on the airplanes you sit next to someone
or you're sitting in the lounge
people ask you what do you do
you see in the western world it's what you do in
the non-western world it is who do you know who
you're connected to with your family and so it is
what do you do i'm an evangelist i'm a preacher
let me tell you a story that happened to me
in a certain country on the face of the
earth can't name the country i was waiting
to fly out after some preaching and i had
five hours until my plane left so some of
my local friends took me into a large shopping
mall to walk around and so i'm sitting in this
nice brand new suv i'm sitting in the back
dressed in my uniform and the police stops the van
the policeman comes up he and the driver are
talking in their language and i'm just sitting
back there after two minutes the police looked
at me and told the driver go well don't say amen
why so as the guy was driving away said what
happened what were the two of you saying
what's the problem why did he stop you he said
i don't have a registration plan well in the
u.s you don't have a registration plate you got
to take it well in michigan 100 200 or they may
take the car right there or take you out of the
car take you to prison i said well why did the
policeman let you go he said i told him i have
a diplomat from the united states in the back
and the police so that's when
remember i said he looked at me
and he thought he looked and how was i dressed
shirt pressed and i had a look on my
face like the book of lamentations
and when he saw me he said this man must be
a diplomat are you with me and so he told the
driver go don't hold up this diplomat no it
happened now i could have been there with a
yeah a cap turned this way
throwback jerseys he would have looked at me and
said a diploma i didn't know prisons had diplomats
let me take you to principle two this is
serious and i'm talking merely to the women
you see why i'm talking to the women
the bible supports me in this position
the problem of dress is mainly a female problem
and the bible acknowledges that first timothy
chapter first verse verse verse chapter two
verse nine in like manner also that women
adorn themselves in modest apparel
the holy ghost inspired paul to target
women notice i said it is mainly a problem
for women now you know what i'm about to say
it's true two men show up in church with the same
suit what do they tell each other nice suit nicer
two women show up with the same dress and they
see and they turn their backs to each other
and one wants to go home and change because they
can't take it how dare you dress the way i dress
are you with me say yes or no now keeping
this in mind let's go to genesis chapter 3.
it's 26 minutes after 12. you have genesis
chapter 3 the bible says now the serpent was
more subtle than any beast of the field which the
lord god had made and he said unto the woman yeah
hath god said he shall not eat of every tree of
the garden and the woman said unto the serpent we
may eat of the fruit of the trees of the garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in the
midst of the garden god hath said he shall not
eat of it neither shall he touch it lest he die
and the serpent said unto the woman ye shall
not surely die for god doth know that in the
day if thereof then your eyes shall be opened
and ye shall be as gods knowing good and evil
and when the woman saw that the tree was good
for food and that it was pleasant to the eyes
in a tree to be desired to make one wise she took
of the fruit thereof and didn't eat and gave also
unto her husband with her in heated e and the eyes
of them both were open for seven and they did one
they knew that they were naked and they
sowed fig leaves together and made themselves
aprons the creation of heaven and earth is
recorded in genesis 1 and intimate details
of adam's home are recorded in chapter 2.
some smart scholars tell you there are two
creation stories there's one the bible is
damaged more by scholars than anybody else
if you read genesis 1 every work of
creation is done by god amen are you with me
when god made adam and eve
everything had been made
everything so that adam and eve could not claim
to have assisted god in making one blade of grass
because god does not need human help to create not
even the angels the angels stood by and clapped
and shouted for joy they did not help an angel
cannot create adam and eve were made last they
could take no credit for the work of god you look
at chapter two god makes the garden in forsake
he puts the trees in verse nine uh he tells adam
he talks about the four rivers in verse 10 to 14.
he tells adam this is your work in 15 and tells
them 16 17 eat don't eat in 18 it's not good that
he should be alone in 1920 names all the animals
21 22 he makes eve all the doing is gone now
the very first act of creation ever done by a
human being was the making of the aprons of leaves
you haven't gotten the significance of what i said
let me say it again the very first recorded work
of human creation and human creation is merely
manipulation of god's created words are you with
me so you take dirt that god made you take leaves
he made you make an apron that is human creation
in quotation marks are you following me the
very first work of creation by a human being
was the creation of the fig leaves the aprons
of fig leaves which were designed to improve
the feeling of guilt by
beautifying where the outside
they could do nothing about
what the inside apart from god
but you don't need god to beautify
the outside you're not listening
now there are two powers that help us no one
is independent of external power you're either
aided by god or you aided by satan what they
did in verse 7 was the work of satan not god's
word what god did in verse 21 that was god's work
unto adam also and to his wife did the lord god
make courts of skins and clothe them let's examine
these two verses listen to verse 7 again and the
eyes of them both were opened and they knew that
they were naked and they sold fig leaves together
and made themselves aprons we have adam and eve
adam and eve adam and eve god is not present
in the creation of this external
adornment god is not present
verse 21 unto adam also and to his wife did the
lord god make coats of scales now god is present
and intimately involved because he makes the coats
the quotes represent the righteousness
of christ which takes care of the inside
but the righteousness of christ on the
inside must have an external expression
that external expression differed vastly from the
way they were clothed in verse seven now a woman
only wearing an apron will turn many men's
heads you didn't get what i said are you with me
and you heard dr lemon the several parts
of the body the bible describes as naked
but when god clothed that woman in verse
21 she was covered from head to foot
so that the effect on the heart
which is the righteousness of
christ working on us must have
an expression on the outside
amen the very first work of a human being
was an attempt to beautify the outside
the bible says that is not the
place of god's primary focus
when samuel went to anointed king at god's
direction in first samuel 16 the bible says that
when eliot came before him verse 6 of 1st samuel
16 that samuel said surely the lord's anointed
is before him you need to understand who samuel
was to grasp the extent of his error you see if a
six-year-old boy makes an error in algebra you can
smile say that skew if einstein makes the error
then we have a story for cnn are you with me
remember when that vice president was his name
couldn't spell potato those of you who were born
then quail huh quilken spelled potato it became
an international story because the vice president
of united states should be able to spell potato
now
here's who he was prophet priest and
king now there weren't kings in his days
those who function as kings were
called what judges so the same thing
essentially samuel was prophet priest and
king now you would think a man who gets direct
information from god who got direct
information from god as a prophet
direct counsel as a priest direct guide us as a
king would not be deceived by outward appearance
the only other living being who is prophet priest
and king is whom christ this man samuel who was
prophet priest and king was deceived by the
outward appearance of a man that god rejected
if outward appearance can deceive samuel who is
considered the greatest of the ancient prophets
if you read acts chapter 3 from samuel and all the
prophets that followed after he was considered the
first of the great prophets if samuel called
as a child could be deceived by what's outside
what about you and me what about us men who
are not prophets we're priests but not kings
god told samuel look not on his countenance not
on the hype of his appearance or stature because
i have refused him for the lord seeth not as man
seeth for man looking from the outward appearance
but god looketh where on the heart now you reason
with me favor number three if god's focus is
the heart why is it the focus of the average
woman christian is the inside or the outside
have you ever wondered how many billions of
dollars are spent every year on cosmetics
there's a whole street in new york
devoted that called madison avenue
you heard the speaker earlier fashion is doing
more to destroy this church than any other power
when god gave instructions to moses to make
garments for for what's his brother's name aaron i
want you to familiarize yourself with what god
told moses go to exodus 28 we shall read verse
2. it's 23 minutes to 1. exodus 28 we'll
read verse 2. ladies do you hate me say no
all right okay i just had to check
i don't want you to think any man likes to see
a badly dressed woman no we're not saying that
at all we love modesty we really do because the
man who looks at a half-naked woman does not want
his woman to dress that way are you following me
are you not listening to me a man looking at a
half-naked woman does not want his woman dressed
like that because he wants to be the only man
looking at her what book did i say exodus what
chapter 28 what first verse two here's what god
told moses read carefully with me and thou shall
make what what kind of garments stop who was aaron
the priest do you know god's original idea for
his people when he called him out of egypt that
the entire nation would be priests go to exodus
19 let's read from verse 4 don't lose exodus 28
put one thing on 28 put another thing on 19 we'll
read from verse 4 listen to god speaking to moses
do you have exodus 19 we read from verse 4 god
says to moses you have seen what i did unto the
egyptians and how i bear you on eagle's wings and
brought you unto myself now therefore if you will
do what obey my voice indeed and do what keep
my covenant then what does the word then suggest
but when you see then what can you assume
something went before are you with me
something has to come before before you have
then which means this is what god's saying
if you do this i will do that there's a sequence
if you obey my voice indeed and keep my covenant
then it shall be a peculiar treasure unto me
above all people for all the earth is mine now
read verse 6 with me and he shall be unto
me what a kingdom of priests now that's it
first peter chapter 2 verse 9 what does it say
for ye are what a chosen one a royal priesthood
but the israelites never lived up to god's
intention for them so god had to choose just
a small group to be priests the family of iran but
his original intention was the entire nation would
be preached his original intention was they would
never fight a war he would fight all the wars
all the sanctuary services
were never god's intention
but when we don't reach one level of understanding
god comes down not he doesn't know his standard he
becomes more kindergarten in the way he
presents the truth are you following me
and so god told uh god said you'll be a kingdom
of priests now ideally and you heard me talk
about ideal and allowed yesterday are you with
me ideally we should all be priests listen now
to exodus 28 verse 2 and thou shalt make what
holy garments for whom aaron represents whom
all the priests and that's what god wants us
to be we must wear holy garments every sabbath
every sabbath what about tuesday
how many days of the week are holy
seven sister are you exceeding god
one how many days are we supposed to be holy
seven then how should we dress on thursday
holy garments you don't like what i'm saying
thou shalt make holy garments for moses
but for aaron now finish the verse for me
there are two qualities that the garments must
have finish the verse for glory and for beauty now
that order is deliberate
what's glory character what is god telling moses
that the garments of aaron should do reflect god
now that kind of thinking makes the world laugh
but if the world will stop and think do you
know there's a garment that reflects rap culture
am i right yes there is a garment
when you see a young man rap
you can tell a rock singer from a
country singer and now you're not
listening to me for those of you listening
by internet in other parts of the world
uh i hope you can follow me you can tell a country
singer from a rock singer they dress differently
you can tell a gospel singer sometimes from
a classical singer their dress differently
i was in guyana south america three years ago four
maybe and some local people were taking me around
and we drove across a river and i was on one
side of the river now you looked across guyana
has some large rivers and i saw two young men on
the far side of the river and i said two mormons
i couldn't see their faces you know what
i saw there was rest i said two mormons
dark pants what color shirt white shirt what color
type dark blue or black a satchel in the hand hair
trimmed neat fish shave clean two mormons i will
give you ten thousand dollars if you can walk
through la and pick out two out for this young man
i will give you twenty thousand dollars if you go
to an adventist academy and pick out the advice
from the non-advertisers you can do it i will
give you fifty thousand if you can pick out the ad
for this in an adventist church from the visitors
yeah you're not listening
you're beginning to smell
the food that's coming up that cost
seven dollars but i want you to listen
i want you to listen i am very serious
god told moses the garments must be holy
and they must reflect glory and beauty women today
reverse that they're dressed for beauty first
and most of the time never get to glory because if
you dress for beauty first glory does not fit in
that's not the way it works are you following
me god has a system if you dress for glory and
you understand glory and you familiarize yourself
with illinois council then you study and you pray
and the spirit of god directs you your
glory in your garment will produce beauty
you must keep in mind god's idea of
beauty is not the world's idea of beauty
there's something called the red carpet and
you and elia should know what the red carpet is
the world makes a big thing about
how people look on the red carpet
are you with me there's a lady called lady
gaga do you have her cds get rid of them
she wore a dress made of meat
i read about meat people try to be as extra
extreme as they can a dress made of meat
hanging all over her and pictures were taken
and people were the dress made of meat because
that's the way the world is excited a few years
ago there was a lady called sister jennifer lopez
she wanted a dress that made
headlines all over the world
and i would not dare to describe the dress
four years ago another one i mean a girl a woman
called a female rapper called the little kim
you see these things they cut they make news i'm
not going looking for them they're on the news
she showed up on an event with one breast
hanging out and just a little uh what you
could stick her on her nipples so that
it became legal and that's how she came
now the world that's what the world promotes
you don't see people on the front page on the
red carpet with a dress that covers them properly
unless it's made for forty thousand dollars
then it becomes sinful because of the excess
and so aaron's garments were for glory
then for beauty ladies if you dress for
glory the men will have virtually no problem
we have to help save one another
amen i was listening to two ladies at my
local church this actually happened they
didn't know i was listening they're
both single two desperate housewives
and um nice ladies that's about 15 years ago and
they were talking how to attract the attention
of a man that's what they were discussing
let me tell you something don't tell anyone
the greatest need of a single woman is not christ
the greatest urge and need of a
single woman is not christ it's a man
now christ is a man but that's not the man
are you listening to me that's why people
will leave christ on his principles and go find
any man because their greatest need is a man
when they get the man the next greatest need
is the child and they will get that child
even if the way they get it is pleases christ
are you sure your greatest of allegiance is to
christ these two women were talking and one
said here's how you get a man to look at you
once said i'm paraphrasing you dress in a
way that causes everything that can shake to
shake that's what once said and i just smiled and
walked to the basement of the church and i heard
it i didn't want them to realize i heard they
would have been very embarrassed because i was
a local out of that church and so i just smiled
because they're very nice people i know them
my brothers my sisters particularly my sisters
when you stand before your closet your
first thought must be which outfit will
reflect god now let me ask you a question this
question is that what you think don't answer me
if that's not your motive whatever you wear
is unpleasing to god i'll tell you why christ
object lesson spirit 3 16 paragraph 2 every
act is judged by the motives that prompted
child guidance page 2 1 paragraph 3 every course
of action has a twofold character and importance
it is virtuous or vicious right or wrong
according to the motive which prompts it
then i ask why did you choose that dress
if god had nothing to do
with it you made a bad choice
let me leave dress why did you choose that
you're hairstyle black
woman why is your hair green
are you with me why is your hair green rabbits eat
grass all day they're not green why is your hair
green and your black woman then you did
it so someone could do what look at you
jesus never sought to draw attention to
himself that doesn't mean he looked as
if he fell off the back of a salvation
army trump but jesus christ the bible
says and when we see him there is no beauty
that we should desire christ was just plain
and simple you know what drew people
to christ not his calvin klein jeans
all these two hundred dollar sneakers
his character it drew people to him
ten to one let me close there's
so many things i want to say
let me repeat if you or i exert a harmful
influence on someone that damages the person
spiritually you have to answer to god we live
in a world where people say i am number one the
big kahuna numero uno in god's eyes you are
your brother's keeper and we need more women
who realize they must be their brother's
keepers men need help to do what's right
and so do women need help from
us watch what you say to a woman
words words can be easily misinterpreted
but my burden is to deal with the women
hope you don't mind and so i'm asking
you from my heart don't dress to get
a man you want a man ask god amen you know
without faith it's impossible to please god
we're christians but there are many things we
don't think god can do we don't believe god can
heal certain sicknesses we don't believe it he
can heal a cold or runny nose but not cancer not
age not her god can't do that that's the way we
think god can't send me my needs god can't send me
a husband and so women say well there are no men
in the church i've got to go outside listen to me
when abraham cast out hagar in genesis 21
she was dying of thirst so was a boy ishmael
and god appeared to her and the bible says in
genesis 21 19. now she is under bush dying of
thirst what she needed was water the bible says
in genesis 21 19 and the lord opened her eyes
and she saw a well of water what she needed
she could not see now the bible doesn't say
god created a well of water it says he opened her
eyes and she saw what was there that she couldn't
see the man you need maybe in front of your eyes
you cannot see him because you're not trusting god
the job you need maybe in front of your eyes you
cannot see it because you're not trusting god
don't tell me there are no men in
the church there may be no men in
your church but god has a man for you
ask him don't take advice from television
and magazines god every good gift and every
perfect gift is where from above and cometh
down from the father of light deliberately
the word father not even god the word father
don't you realize god loves you as if no one
else exists you go to god you know when i pray
to god sometimes i imagine a lot of things
sometimes i imagine i'm sitting at his feet
literally sitting down and just talking to
and there's some people i pray for because
the circumstances are so bad i say father i am
putting this man this woman right on your lap
literally in my mind i am you have
you ever put a baby in somebody's lap
father this person's circumstance is rough i
am placing this person right on your lap and
there's a lady i pray for her circumstances
so bad i place her right inside god's tunic
i said father i am placing this woman right inside
your coat she is resting against your divine skin
now you go to god you say god give me a mind like
christ in the way i dress the way i conduct myself
take away flirtatiousness from me so that
by my conduct i do not mislead any man
yes i'd like to be married father if
that's your will leave that man to me
you are responsible for the influence you
exert over men in insofar as you can control it
by the power of god you are supposed to control
it so that i was at the airport in johannesburg
and i saw a lady and the minute i saw her i said
that woman is modest she has respect for herself
and she's some kind of christian just by the way
it is clear it was clear to me she deliberately
dressed in such a way to cover herself it was
deliberate and i wanted to go and tell her
something but i said no she may misunderstand she
may think i'm making a prophetic pass so i didn't
but i looked at and i admired her dress but the
outfit was attractive but she looked like someone
with self-respect with a love from modesty and
quiet dignity and i just admired that for her
ladies i want you to make a commitment
to god that as far as life in you
by the grace of god you will make every conscious
effort not to exert a carnal influence on men
whether you're single or married because
married women still want to know they look
good are you with me married women
still want to know they look good
i want you to make a
commitment father by your grace
plus my effort i will do nothing to
exert a sinful influence upon men
how many of you will make that
commitment i want you to raise your hand
do you mean it i'm talking to the
women do you mean it you do stand up
i'll ask you to do something else it's hard
if the dresses outfits you bought because of
its carnal effect on people when you get home
get rid of it don't give it away are you
with me you're spreading sin get rid of it
let me say it again if there's anything in your
closet you deliberately bought because of its
stimulating nature get rid of it don't give it
away change the way you think have mercy on us men
please
let's pray father in heaven
we thank you for our sisters as i stand in this
pulpit day god having delivered a difficult sermon
it is my belief that every woman standing truly
wants a place in your kingdom and those listening
via internet their god in heaven give to them
and to us the men the mind of christ give us a
mind that understands that whatever influence we
exert god holds us responsible and we must pay
and so i ask you father bless my beloved sisters
grant them your spirit their god change the way
they think when they dress let them dress for
glory first then for beauty but seven days a week
whatever they wear must be holy because they
reflect their father the god of heaven and earth
wherever they have sinned in this area forgive
them god and forgive us for reacting too quickly
please have mercy on all of us and grant us as a
church family your spirit your power dear god in
this place and our people watching by the internet
give us that power their father that we help each
other upward bless us sustain us and father save
us into that kingdom and when we arrive on the
pearly gates on the sea of glass let us meet
those who have been won by our godly influence
and let no one burning in the flames of hell
point to us in that city and say it's because of
your influence i am lost please god help us to see
the gravity of this situation bless us and save us
when you come i pray in jesus name let all of us
say amen and amen god bless you you may be seated